toujours trouvé ça un peu naze c'est
d'aller aux abords de la zone 51 enfin
ça sert à rien et en fait c'est quand
même pas mal
une atmosphère un peu bizarre enfin tu
dis voilà se passe des choses de l'autre
côté
[Musique]
oh
donc au total j'ai vu neuf vaisseaux
spatiaux et tout était différent comme
s'il avait légué
[Musique]
j'ai rencontré bob lazare des bus 89
grâce à un ami commun et bob m'a raconté
une histoire incroyable je me suis dit
que si seulement une toute petite partie
de cette histoire était vraie ce sera
probablement le plus grand scoop de tous
les temps
[Musique]
comment savez vous qu'il s'agit d'une
technologie extraterrestre
ça ne peut être que ça et pourquoi donc
tu portes mais une fois ce volet avec ça
[Musique]
croft
je pense qu'ici les extraterrestres et
notre armée fonds de recherche kotaku
[Musique]
c'est dans la partie civile et je peux
pas aller plus loin vraiment je peux pas
aller plus loin c'est une zone ultra
surveillé ultra sécurisé vers les
barbelés et ses six jeux les plus loin
je peux me faire arrêter aller en prison
[Musique]